bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 24 octobre du 7 8 sur tvfils 78 en
direct si vous nous rejoignez à 18h
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
aujourd'hui nous allons revenir sur les
déserts médicaux qui inquiète enfin de
semaine dernière une femme de 35 ans
perdait son enfant alors et qu'elle se
rendait à la maternité de Brive une
maternité située à plus d'une heure de
chez elle le département des Yvelines ne
connaît pas une telle situation une
telle problématique pour autant la
situation à l'heure actuelle est tout de
même préoccupante en plateau à l'endroit
bonsoir du FC Que Choisir Yvelines sur
l'antenne de Houilles plus
particulièrement l'association de
consommateurs qui a rendu public une
étude nationale sur cette question elle
pointe d'ailleurs le lien structurel
existant entre déserts médicaux
dépassement d'honoraires et médecin
spécialistes on va en parler en détail
dans quelques instants mais d'abord une
première question est-ce que dans les
Yvelines la situation est véritablement
préoccupante sur ces questions de désert
médicaux
le reflet un peu de ce qui se passe en
France vous savez comme moi qu'il y a
certaines certains secteurs qui sont
myélodiques d'autres c'est vrai que là
en région parisienne on est myosotis que
en Corrèze justement où dans la Somme ou
d'autres départements qui sont un peu
plus
enfin un peu moins
bien servi c'est vrai que nous avons
pris en compte plusieurs critères nous
avons pris en compte le critère
comment dire géographique c'est-à-dire
le nombre de
praticiens qu'il y a dans le département
alors nous avons pris d'un côté les
médecins généralistes
les généralistes simples et d'un autre
côté trois spécialistes qui ne demandent
pas de recommandations écrite de la part
de ces généralistes gynécologie
ophtalmologie et pédiatrie on va voir
tous les détails justement de cette
enquête qui a été menée par UFC Que
Choisir ce sera dans quelques instants
vous restez bien en plateau avec nous on
va détailler tout ça auparavant le
sommaire également de ce soir en images
les autres sujets que nous allons
aborder au cours de cette heure
d’émission elle école Victor Hugo aux
Clayes-sous-Bois sera bien reconstruite
le chantier est en cours et les élèves
pourront découvrir leurs nouvelles
établissement à la rentrée prochaine le
château de La Coudre à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux a accueilli
pendant plusieurs années les activités
de la communauté d'agglomération de 50
ans en Yvelines depuis le départ des
services à Trappes le lieu est inoccupé
un projet de maison de retraite et dans
les cartons il avance plutôt bien
Richard Anconina Jean-Luc Lahaye et
mille et images Peter et slown les stars
des années 80 était présente ce mardi
soir à l'UGC de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à l'occasion
de la sortie du film stars 80 et puis 10
monde pour grimper 10 mètres des
pompiers d'Île-de-France viennent de
participer à Montigny le Bretonnet à une
démonstration de grimper de cordes
toutes les images seront à découvrir ce
soir
cyclisme à présent avec cette
information Christian prud'hommes le
directeur du Tour de France a dévoilé
officiellement ce matin 11h30 le
parcours de 2013 cette centième édition
partira de Corse mais surtout s'achèvera
par une étape inédite reliant Versailles
aux Champs-Élysées avec une arrivée
nocturne le 21 juillet aux alentours de
21h30 une dernière étape longue de 118
km autre information qui est tombée
aujourd'hui et je vous propose un long
retour en arrière en juin 2001 la
commune de Manille et hameaux elle
découvrait un déficit record celui du
SICTOM le syndicat de traitement des
ordures ménagères 15 millions d'euros en
2007 la commune avait quitté ce syndicat
une procédure juridique avait alors été
engagée contre Jean-Philippe Passel
ancien maire adjoint de Rambouillet pour
sa gestion jugée délictueuse du SICT le
tribunal de la 11e chambre de Paris a
prononcé aujourd'hui sont verdict il a
été condamné à 18 mois de prison avec
sursis 20 000 euros d'amende et 5 ans de
privation de droits civique et familiaux
l'équipe de stars 80 était donc à l'UGC
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce mardi soir
pour une avant-première du film et nous
les avons rencontrés au cours de la
seconde partie du 7 8 de ce 24 octobre
interview de Richard Anconina de
Jean-Luc Lahaye Peter et Stone ou encore
Émile et images ou encore Patrick
Hernandez voici déjà un aperçu de
l'ambiance qui régnait hier soir à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
les démons de minuit mais aussi
confidences pour confidences ou encore
Born to Be Alive des tubes qui ont
marqué les années 80 et qui sont
aujourd'hui devenus des incontournables
plébiscités par le public en témoigne
l'accueil réservé aux chanteurs devenus
acteurs lors de l'avant-première de
stars 80 à l'UGC de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux mardi soir
moi j'étais plutôt habitué à rentrer
dans des sales feutrés des gens
concentrés sur un film avec parfois
quelqu'un qui fait du bruit en toussant
ou en mangeant des chips et Tonton
immédiatement chiant et alors là le mec
est pas debout sur son fauteuil il passe
pour un âne
ou l'histoire de deux copains qui
décident d'organiser une tournée à
travers la France avec les gloires
passées du Top 50
on parle de nous là star des années 80
avec Emile et image Peter et Stone début
de soirée Jean-Pierre Mader Sabrina Lio
Cookie Dingler Jean-Luc Lahaye Jeanne
Mas Gilbert Montagné etc etc etc c'est
super super à partir même pas mon nom
c'est pas un concert filmé c'est pas un
karaoké
c'est pas un conseil à filmer c'est pas
une télévision sur grand écran non c'est
un hommage à
ces gens-là à cette période est-ce
qu'ils ont parce qu'ils ont installé
pour très longtemps dans la mémoire
collective dans la mémoire de dans la
culture française enfin de la chanson
française t'inquiète pas tout super bien
Sabrina qu'est-ce qui a motivé votre
tour
de toute façon c'est pas vous les stars
c'est vos chansons voilà personne
connaît leur prénom c'est quoi mon
prénom Tic et Tac début et soirée
n'importe qui peut chanter vos chansons
extra franchement extra le fait de
revoir les tubes et tout ça de les
réentendre ça m'ouvre ça fait du bien
c'est un truc de fou star 80 à l'affiche
depuis ce 24 octobre plusieurs millions
de spectateurs sont attendus viendra
ensuite le temps pour les chanteurs de
repartir sur scène déclinaisons du film
projeté en salle le spectacle de la
troupe reprendra la route début 2013
on quitte les paillettes des années 80
pour se retrouver sur ce plateau et
parler à présent d'une problématique de
santé les déserts médicaux à l'endroit
est toujours en plateau avec nous membre
du FC Que Choisir et j'évoquais en début
d'émission ce tragique fait divers cette
femme enceinte qui perdait son enfant
car la maternité où elle se rendait où
elle devait se rendre était trop loin de
son domicile à une heure de route le
gouvernement a réagi ces derniers jours
et cette phrase de François Hollande le
drame nous appelle une nouvelle fois
encore à nœud rien accepter en matière
de désert médical vous avez mené avec
votre association au niveau national une
enquête sur ces déserts médicaux elle a
été menée en 2011 ce qui ressort c'est
que les Yvelines ne sont pas non plus
épargnés on en parlait brièvement au
début d'émission par ces déserts
médicaux l'enquête s'est intéressée au
nombre de médecins généralistes dans le
département aussi aux spécialités
gynécologies ophtalmologie et pédiatrie
on va en voir les principaux résultats
sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec une
infographie cette carte des fractures
sanitaires présentées par l'UFC Que
Choisir le taux de médecin généraliste
pour 100000 habitants et si l'on
consulte les données pour ces 7 communes
de l'agglomération il y a des disparités
elles sont assez énormes entre
Magny-les-Hameaux par exemple qualifiée
de désert médical au contraire de
Trappes pourquoi y a-t-il de tels
disparité entre ces différentes communes
pourquoi des écarts aussi grands
l'attrait de
l'attrait des revenus il faut quand même
savoir
les médecins touchent une aide pour
s'installer bon ils ont tous la même
aide lorsqu'il s'installe sur trappe il
toucheront plus que s'il s'installent
l'amour pas pour l'instant d'accord non
nous avions prévu justement des décides
d'établir un équilibre mais ça n'était
pas été pris en compte ce qu'on a pris
en compte avec vous n'avez pas évoqué
c'est le temps de trajet maximal que met
un patient pour rejoindre
un représentant du corps médical que que
vous avez évoqué alors il faut savoir
que pour un médecin généraliste c'est 30
minutes en moyenne et que nous avons
pris comme base et 45 minutes pour un
spécialiste
alors au niveau des différents
enseignements avec une enquête sur ces
spécialités un gynécologie ophtalmologie
pédiatrie et même constat partout donc
les Yvelines sont victimes de cette
fracture sanitaire oui véritablement ça
sera du comment ça veut dire qu'il est
très difficile d'obtenir des rendez-vous
tout simplement c'est très long
pour certains oui certains endroits il y
a très peu de médecins c'est vrai vous
venez de l'évoquer
vous avez manié l'amour mais vous avez
aussi Andrésy joueur Pontchartrain qui
sont des villes je ne dirais pas
sinistré mais beaucoup moins bien loti
et puis vous avez les autres qui sont un
peu mieux un peu mieux l'outils au point
de vue médecin généraliste je précise
après il existe aussi d'autres
professions
les pédiatres qui ne sont pas trop mal
lotis
et vous arrivez ensuite sur les les
professions ou il y a de moins en moins
de spécialistes je prends un exemple sur
par exemple melon vous prenez l'exemple
de melon il y avait trois ophtalmo il en
reste une
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de relève
une spécialité qui n'intéresse pas les
étudiants en médecine alors vous savez
comme moi vous avez entendu parler que
pour les études il y a eu des des
contraintes plus fortes de mise et on
mettra un certain temps à récupérer
parce que le précédent gouvernement n'a
pas réussi à compenser ses cette
diminution
on verra si celui-ci arrive ça c'est un
autre problème mais toujours est-il que
dans vous prenez les ophtalmos il y a
96% de
d'ophtalmo qui sont en
désert en zone désertique qui représente
le désert on est en désert médical sur
96% et
en gynéco alors là c'est l'hécatombe
c'est 100%
100% vous voulez un rendez-vous avec un
gynéco il faut attendre un temps
incroyable et certains gynéco certaines
gynéco refusent de prendre de nouveaux
patients donc c'est vrai que ça peut
amener à des drames je ne reviendrai pas
sur le problème qui s'est passé dans le
dans le centre du côté de la Corrèze
c'est un autre domaine que nous
évoquerons va vous faire certainement
plus tard mais c'est vrai que c'est
quand même embêtant de de trouver des
généralités des généraux des
spécialistes de ces domaines
d'arriver à avoir si vous avez une
urgence par exemple je parle à titre
personnel j'ai eu un problème
ophtalmique il y a quelques temps
je suis passé en priorité mais j'ai
quand même dû attendre c'est quand même
un comble voilà
il a fallu attendre et c'est une
situation qui se rend compte de plus en
plus souvent c'est ce qui ressort de
l'étude que vous avez menée si on prend
en compte uniquement les médecins qui ne
pratiquent pas les dépassements
d'honoraires à la situation est encore
plus compliquée notamment dans le sud
des Yvelines du côté de Chevreuse de
Saint-Rémy les difficiles de trouver un
médecin qui ne pratique pas c'est
dépassements d'honoraires
c'est un des constat que vous avez tiré
de cette étude c'est important de le
mettre en valeur pourquoi vous avez
souhaité sortir justement ces chiffres
et les mettre sur la place publique
c'était pour avoir un document de
travail et montrer que ce ne sont pas
seulement des sentiments des patients
qui souhaitent prendre des rendez-vous
alors c'était d'abord l'étude a été
faite depuis la fin de l'année 2011 et
le nouveau gouvernement devait s'occuper
courant novembre de ce problème la date
a été avancée nous avons dû agir un peu
un peu plus rapidement que prévu
il est vrai que nos chiffres sont quand
même fiables puisqu'ils ont été pris
d'après Amélie qui est le site Internet
de la Sécu de la CNAV Caisse Primaire
d'Assurance Maladie en UF c'est que
choisir fait aussi des propositions
politiques d'incitation par exemple
primal installation rémunération
complémentaire qui ont prouvé leur
inefficacité pour EFC il faut limiter
les installations de médecins dans des
zones surdotées voilà exactement et ça
on proposait justement de de ne plus les
aider ou beaucoup moins et d'aider
beaucoup plus
ceux qui se mettent dans des zones plus
plus défavorisées parce que dans les
déserts médicaux vous avez
vous n'avez pas seulement
une absence de médecin mais vous avez
aussi des gens qui n'ont pas des revenus
assez importants pour avoir accès à des
soins spécialisés vous avez des
personnes âgées des smicards des gens
avec des faibles revenus des
situations difficiles et
c'est ce qu'on voulait empêcher on
voulait essayer d'aider au maximum
les médecins qui je dirais se dévouent
et retrouve l'esprit de du serment
d'Hippocrate faut-il aussi imposer au
médecin leur première implantation
lorsqu'il sort de l'école de la
formation c'est la question que nous
avons posée aujourd'hui puis vous
pourrez réagir ensuite non moi je pense
que c'est pas une bonne idée
ça veut dire que de toute façon il reste
quelques temps et puis après ils
s'enfuit quoi donc non je pense que
c'est une solution oui parce que c'est
ça devient un désert complètement la
France alors bon il faut quand même faut
leur donner un petit peu de
qui prennent leur responsabilité quoi
quand même c'est pas qu'ils aillent pas
tout sur la Côte d'Azur non non
je pense que chacun est libre d'exercer
là où il veut qu'il démarre ou qu'il est
déjà de l'expérience même s'il y a une
pénurie oui c'est plutôt aux patient de
se déplacer
voilà on a pas des on a des avocats
comme idovis mais pas forcément des
médecins commis d'office oui il y a des
côtés oui il y a des côtés non c'est
vrai que la pénurie des médecins en
campagne ça pose un problème bon leur
condition de travail ça me paraît paraît
difficile aussi gagne moins ils sont à
corvéables à merci jour et nuit
voilà après
l'imposer peut-être provoquer des
je sais pas des situations favorables
d'implantation des médecins
parce que certaines personnes ont des
problèmes justement pour se déplacer et
puis avoir le médecin le plus proche
possible
à l'endroit donc pour l'UFC Que choisir
quel est votre avis est-ce qu'il faut
imposer au médecin leur première
implantations imposer peut-être pas mais
inciter fortement oui
on peut inciter justement fiscalement
ne pas aider ceux qui sont déjà en
situation favorable et qui vont gagner
honorablement leur vie ce n'est pas un
reproche ils font des études mais
simplement
des médecins qui vont aller dans des
zones difficiles des zones avec des
revenus modestes
il faut les aider
leur donner une incitation
on n'a pas imposé pour autant
on est en démocratie avant de terminer
on va juste donc parler de cet accord
trouvé hier mardi entre la sécurité
sociale et les médecins pour encadrer
les dépassements d'honoraires à corps
qualifier d'historique par les
signataires le seuil de dépassement est
limité à 150% soit 70 euros pour une
consultation remboursée sur la base de
28 euros c'est assez technique mais on
parle d'accord historique difficile à
obtenir vous le savez il y a beaucoup de
discussions ce système est très complexe
qu'elle est le regard que vous portez
dessus sur ces questions de dépassement
dans l'horaire et cet accord qui a été
trouvé je trouve que c'est déplorable
parce qu'on avait parlé de l'égalité
d'accès aux soins pour les patients et
on s'en éloigne parce que
150% nous nous demandions de supprimer
progressivement les 40% de supplément
qui sont remboursés par les mutuelles en
général parce que certaines mutuelles
pas toutes mais là on arrive à 150%
grand mot qui vont diminuer sur trois
ans
selon la bonne volonté des praticiens
connaissant l'esprit sans vouloir être
méchant l'esprit français
cela m'étonnerait qu'on y arrive donc
votre proposition c'est de plafonner ces
déplacements à hauteur de 40 %. oui et
même de les supprimer merci à l'endroit
UFC Que choisir d'être venu sur ce
plateau vous voulez ajouter un dernier
mot je vous en prie je suis de
l'association locale de Houilles parce
que nous sommes cette association tout à
fait ce que j'avais précisé en début
d'entretien mais vous faites bien de le
redire UFC Que Choisir donc sur
l'antenne de votre Merci à VOUS Alain